some people they hit it right away they
get famous very early on in their career
you it took some time for you to become
a success yeah a long time what was when
you're starting off tell us like an
acting job
early on when you're just starting out
what my first job I got because I called
a casting director up I met at the
workshop and I said this is niecy Nash
and I said I'm broke I got a baby and I
need a job he's right you're gonna just
say what you need in this life and so I
I just said it I'm broke I got a baby
and I need a job he said be down here at
3 o'clock but I almost lost this job
because I didn't know any better and I
didn't know the audition process no
agent no manager no nothing just walked
in cold you didn't know what they're
doing right and it was about 15 people
just removing boys on the side with
Whoopi Goldberg and Drew Barrymore okay
all right young Matthew McConaughey okay
and I walked in and I it was under five
lines I read my lines and the director
said thank you and I said you welcome
and he said thank you and I said don't
mention it and he said thank you you may
go I said Oh y'all are dismissing me I
said well did you pick me this is great
you're supposed to say thank you so much
and then just wait and be did you pick
and he said someone will let you know
dear said let me know we and I got a
baby and I'm sorry to tell him that I
got a baby
almost got kicked out but here's the
thing they ended up offering me the job
but they said we need you to be in New
York tomorrow so I'm thinking this is
someone will come and pick you up so I'm
thinking I'm just gonna get a ride in a
Toyota Camry and you know we're gonna
get to the airport sure there was a limo
in front of my house for 30 minutes I
almost missed the flight cuz me and my
mother thought the lady next door died
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this fiction are you and your mom
looking at this big black car oh my god
that's so sad she passed can't be for me
yeah can't be for me hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please